décidément la sphère alvaro démarre n'en
finit plus de rebondissements et
d'accusation alors que dimanche soir
lors du clasico psg om les deux hommes
se sont insultés sur le terrain
l'attaquant brésilien avait dans un
premier temps dénoncé les insultes
racistes proférées par son adversaire
sauf qu'aujourd'hui la faire tourner en
défaveur de neymar car ce dernier aurait
proféré à son tour des insultes cette
fois-ci homophobes contre alvaro
gonzalez c'est la chaîne de télévision
espagnole pôle télévision qui a sorti
ses images inédites un nouveau
rebondissement qui pourrait compter sur
la décision de la commission de
discipline de la lfp qui doit se tenir
ce soir au sujet de cet incident
aujourd'hui de nombreux supporters
marseillais ont posté sur internet les
extraits de cette altercation
accompagné du hashtag neymar homophobe
alors affaires démarre comprenez vous
les accusations d'homophobie
et oui c'est vrai que c'est voilà ça est
encore rebondi aujourd'hui c'était sur
twitter toute la journée et c'est vrai
que la polémique enfle entre neymar est
donc alvaro rodriguez est ce que neymar
est maintenant coupable gilles verdez
balin visiblement toutes les images ont
été disséqués on lit sur les lèvres sais
pas si je peux le dire en espagnol mais
c'est pourtant marc icône c'est à dire
voilà je le traduis en français [ __ ]
[ __ ] de paix les [ __ ] de pelles et
donc ça fait très mal
et alors qu'on trouve rien pour le
racisme ça ça peut lui valoir dix
matches de suspension si la ligue pour
si la ligue détermine que ç'a bien été
dit mais là c'est en train peu de
basculer lors ces clans contre klan ya
rien de beaucoup de d'insulter des deux
côtés il faut se méfier mais là à
l'heure où on parle c'est vrai que
neymar est dans une situation un peu
délicate wii iphone jusqu au même titre
que je ne pense pas qu alvaro soit
raciste je suis convaincu que neymar
n'est pas homophobe
là on va trop loin dans le fait de
disséquer alors effet tous les jours ses
côtés une occasion de se taire
il aurait dû voilà pas rentrer dans
cette polémique de álvaro raciste mais
là est ce qu'on peut arrêter disséquer
je voulais d'hier on croirait aux
experts à miami va falloir arrêter de
dire qu'est ce qu'il a dit dans sa
bouche machin évidemment que c'est pas
bien les insultes mais il faut pas les
criées il faut pas les encourager ne va
pas regarder ce qu'il a dit peut-être
dans sa salive sous la gorge entre de
raclage dois dire ça
on parle que de ça on peut parler de
football
on parle clé dans ce sens mais non c'est
le moment d'arrêter il avoue 10 des
sportives et c'est lui qui s'est
toujours vraiment mais oui là il à ce
qu'il n'a eu malheureusement gilles il a
expliqué maintenant il a eu ce qu'ils
méritaient que tu t'entraînes avec un
mec je vous ai dit moi que ce n'était
pas des bonhommes il parle de son père
un mois quand quand j'ai un sultanat qui
m'insultent ensuite je vais pas dire
après on attend de voir l'arbitré lui
dire ce que tu m'as dit un gamin fallait
pas aller voir l'arbitré il a été voir
les arbitres
maintenant il est une enquête et c'est
en train de tourner contre lui
malheureusement c'est dommage
maintenant s'il ya des insultes
homophobes il faut qu'ils payent et
pareil si le bar où il a eu des insultes
travailliste il faut qu'ils payent alors
quand un bad boy charges est très fourni
qu'à ça continue ce et sponsoring dans
le sport qui est un pote merci content
d'être là qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement avec neymar parce que c'est
vrai que c'est tous les jours des
rebondissements et est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas des gens qui veulent aussi la peau
de néma alors la peau c'est un peu dur
de voir un peu de mémoire vous faut être
très solide mais je pense surtout que
neymar il a fait tellement mousser la
faire sur les réseaux sociaux on vous
lance eu un peu ce se porter comme
victime
mais est-ce que ça a été le cas il a
riposté il a eu le soutien beaucoup
d'amis beaucoup de gens très influents
sur les réseaux sociaux hilare posté sur
ces story il a fait vraiment monter la
sauce il fallait s'attendre à un retour
du clan alvaro et je pense qu'ils ont
passé leur vie à disséquer toutes les
images comme l'a dit francesca c'est
triste mais c'est de bonne guerre
oui valérie même le gouvernement
brésilien sans aimer puisque le
ministère de l'éducation de l'égalité
des femmes et cetera a condamné alvaro
en prenant fait et cause pour neymar
avant que ben le vent ne tourne et que
même les conducteurs
alors il ya le président de la
fédération française de football qu'a
qui a réagi sur le racisme dans le
football il a dit noël le graet il a dit
sur un match il peut y avoir des écarts
non on est à moins de 1% de difficultés
aujourd'hui quentin blake marque un but
tout le stade est debout
le phénomène raciste dans le sport et
dans le football en particulier n'existe
pas dit n'importe quoi lui les graves
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ce
monsieur c'est n'importe quoi le vrai
problème il est pas là et lille dans la
banalisation de ces insultes parce que
ça fuse de tout le temps depuis toujours
ça qu'il faut interdire ça maintenant il
faut être ferme c'est la banalisation de
ces grossièretés si tu te le montant des
mises en chantier
mais alors les a entendus et c'est en
plus c'est médiatisé
j'en arrive qu est-ce qui risquent
démarré que risque alvaro uribe à naïma
là ce soir y risque pour la brutalité
ses sept matches mais là si les paroles
sont avérées ça va être dix matches
c'est l'article 9 comportement voilà
c'est ça comportement raciste ou
discriminatoire pour quelqu'un liée à
son orientation sexuelle qui a derrière
vous et là c'est dix matches alors
vraiment dit match ce soir